Kevin Taylor managing director for BTN
aphis if 'ok it's a great question i
believe china is half the bridge towards
recovery the investments the chinese
government have made into the
infrastructure in shine has helped I'll
see you increase growth back to a
percent or midi a percent which is which
is excellent but half the bridge only
the other half of the bridge is the u.s.
I'm definitely seeing early signs of
recovery in terms of planning over the
last three or four weeks and feel very
confident as we see the next six months
to one year we'll see much more positive
environment for doing business China's
played his part it's also supported the
dollar in the process under the dollar
means finding the lower the pressure at
the moment census that's a short team
situation so it's paid as part in the
world economy and I think we can look
forward to better times thank you